one Wisconsin now which is a liberal
advocacy group they have found that the
Walton family which of course owns
Walmart that their fortune is equal to
the wealth of the bottom forty two
percent of Americans combined that is
absolutely incredible let's take a look
as of May 2013 Walmart had four hundred
sixty nine billion in sales with 2.2
million employees including 1.3 million
in the United States
Walmart is owned by stockholders but the
Walton family has control of the company
with about half of the shares in 2010
the wealth of the six Walton family
heirs was eighty nine point five billion
which is twenty two percent higher than
2007 so they're doing all right
the median wealth of the American
families in 2010 was 77339 percent lower
than 2007 and the Walton family wealth
in 2010 was as large as the wealth of
the bottom forty eight point eight
million families in the u.s. or 41 point
five percent of all American families
and then just one final number on this
the Forbes 400 list in 2013 says that
the Waltons family wealth has grown to a
hundred and forty four point seven
billion dollars okay now I don't
begrudge anyone's success I think it is
the I had a feeling you do no I don't
regret genuine success I believe it is
the American dream to build a business
and to make money and reap the rewards
of your hard work and all that but this
is completely completely out of control
I just not a control I don't know how
they make ends meet I mean they
definitely how I mean they can't pay
their employees a living wage how would
they do that I mean they just don't have
enough money they're not making enough
revenue I I read a Facebook post today
from one of my libertarian friends right
and he made an argument that he hates
minimum wage he thinks we should get rid
of minimum wage altogether but then he
made the argument that Walmart employees
you know with what they do
as a living do they deserve to make more
money and I commented back to him and I
said yeah [ __ ]
they do deserve to make more money when
we are subsidizing them okay when we are
subsidizing the health care and the the
food of people that are working
full-time we have a problem why should
taxpayers have to provide government
programs for people that are already
working 40 plus hours a week that
doesn't make any sense at all it's
coming out of our pockets when you
should be coming out of the walton
family's pockets it should be coming out
of the shareholders pop-up pockets we
have a system right now that is so
broken the idea that we have companies
that refuse to pay their employees a
living wage is problematic we need to
increase the minimum wage companies are
not going to do that themselves because
they have a profit motive they are
immoral and they don't give a [ __ ] about
anything other than making money
they're amoral they're ok that's perfect
here's the thing about it's not just
about the Walton Valley it's about our
entire system we have become a nation of
hoarders yes and at the same time that
the the capitalist consumerist model is
based on the untenable premise that we
have unlimited national natural
resources at the same time we've built
in the constant fear of scarcity so that
we are raised to believe you have to
hold on to whatever you've got and it's
all up to you because the governor is no
one's going to step in no it's going to
help you it's all up to you so the
Walton family that I can't blame them
for being insane they are at the very
top of the ladder
in an insane system that is constantly
telling them that everybody wants to
take away their money i I do begrudge
them I judge them I don't blame them for
their madness I totally blame them for
their madness their look there
I understand that there is an incentive
to make as much money as possible but as
a person as like as a corporation as a
company right it is a moral like you
want to make as much money as possible
but how do the members of that family
look at all of these people that are
living in poverty their own employees
and live with themselves
I think what they would argue is that in
there and all the estate well first off
they probably say they give a lot to
charity fine okay and whatever they give
is a tiny pittance of of course what
they really have but I think what they
would also say is what we also employ a
zillion people at our state's and let
you know that somehow that by them
living like kings and I don't know how
that how each one of the six of them
live but I'm just I'm sure they're doing
all right yeah better than Kings
actually but so I think that that's what
they'd argue that they're you know they
believe in trickle-down because it's
nice that we even trickle-down when
you're on the top but it's not trickling
down again these people are working
full-time jobs and they're still living
in poverty it's not right I I definitely
agree with you I mean is that we should
we should increase the minimum wage that
that there should be a forced
redistribution of wealth that is built
into the system and that that the the
Regan premise that you know I for one am
tired of being trickled on you know it's
not that is not how I choose to to how I
would choose to live given the options
but I think that while we we they have
been indoctrinated into a worldview as
strongly as I as a left-leaning liberal
have and they genuinely believe that
once you start giving up the wealth boy
you're gonna wind up just being equal to
everybody else in their minds that would
be the most horrible thing ever because
they see how the people live who they
under pay and they don't want to be that
okay so what is what is actually the
better system because we talked about
this on The Young Turks all the time and
I really believe that in income
inequality is going to be the next real
issue of the next ten years and we're
seeing that already with the Occupy
movements and the one-percent and all
that but what really is the better
system I guess you could argue maybe
that some of the Nordic countries that
have money now and that are
redistributing to their people but
they're homogeneous societies that don't
have all the immigration issues that we
like there's so much difference between
the way America operates and the way
like what would be the better you
regulate capitalism okay we have this
issue with deregulation we have this
issue with acting as though our
employees our middle class is not
important to our economy
you want a thriving economy you need a
strong middle-class why did we forget
that all of a sudden right I mean this
argument keeps getting made about oh
well if you increase the minimum wage
all of these companies are gonna get rid
of the majority of their employees
really if you increase the minimum wage
you have a stronger middle class that
buys your product it's simple supply and
demand right and you are not going to
refuse to hire more employees because
you don't want to pay them a living wage
if you have people coming into your
store and buying your product you have
to deal with that demand you have to
hire more people to shell out more of
your products the myth of supply-side
economics that that you build at the top
and then there'll be you know it makes
no sense but even what you're describing
comes from the assumption of a
consumerist base that we just have to
have people buying more stuff and then
everything will be fine if with as long
as everyone's buying things everything
will be fine
which again assumes unlimited natural
resources it assumes constant production
and and built-in obsolescence and all
that nonsense if you want to if you ask
me the way ultimately it should work is
that feudalism evolves into capitalism
capitalism ultimately creates enough
wealth that it can evolve into socialism
so that the basic needs of everybody are
covered there's you know I don't believe
that the pursuit of happiness can begin
until the pursuit of lunch is covered
and I think that that humanity should be
able to live in the wealthiest time in
history humanity should be able to live
without fear of hunger without fear of
the cold without fear of a medical
emergency that the basic human needs
should be taken care of and then we can
begin to make decisions about how we
want to spend our national resources and
not just be dealing with how do we keep
everyone from starving yeah yeah I mean
my final thought on this is just you
know that not only is the income
inequality a problem but I also think
that places like Walmart they take away
something that's so important to the
American dream which is they close all
these mom-and-pop stores all these
people that
want to own their own business and build
the very things that the Waltons have
right and then they close all of them
and then you get all these people that
are working for giant corporations that
barely pay them and then it affects
their happiness and then they get on the
prescription drug like it's all it's
such a self-fulfilling I have properly
bring us on I have to quote George
Carlin on this one yeah they call it the
American dream because to believe in it
you have to be asleep